foreign
right after my graduation in 2019. I
joined the other cyber security analyst
just like every other work I face new
challenges every day and then I realized
I might need some professional help and
certification to improve my knowledge
and then I came across simply learns
certification course which goes by
Advanced executive program in cyber
security from IIT Bangalore this
certification has helped me through my
skills and trust me my confidence has
grown over time and the salary hike of
40 was just like the cherry on the top
hi my name is Akash Raymond I live in
Delhi I work as a cyber security analyst
and part-time weightlifting coach
and as a part of my responsibility my
work was to check for any suspicious
activity on my IIT framework the job was
not easy so I realized that I was still
new to all the terms like malware and
attack IPS
then I looked up online for a course
that would help me
to clear my fundamentals to the advanced
level simply one course was the one I
was looking for
the curriculum was good in fact its
association with triple it Bangalore
really helped me to make my decision
this course was specifically designed
for working professionals and they
ensured it that it should be flexible
and the Learners can learn at their own
pace
so my course and my classes ended in
around by the end of July and
approximately within two months I was
promoted from cyber security NS level 1
to cyber security analyst level 2. and
on the top of that I got a salary hike
of 40 and it feels great
I'm seeing myself applying those skills
I learned from the course to my security
monitoring duties
and now I think I'm ready to face new
challenges
I think I'm someone who prepares himself
for new challenges I think I have
adopted this attitude from weightlifting
I am a self-made coach and I provide
weightlifting coaching to some of my
clients so colleges doesn't teach you
everything there are some things we have
to learn on our own and it's amazing to
have platforms like simply learn that
helps us and guide us through our
upskilling journey and just like our
bodies Our Minds needs to be trained and
upskilling can do that